hey guys it's just Jade I thought it
would be really fun to do a year and
seven month of the air pods I've had
them since the very beginning and I
think since the beginning especially
right when I first got them I had some
mixed reviews because for whatever
reason they would not stay in my ears
but now I think my ears have officially
conformed to the air pots and it's kind
of crazy because I go running with them
now I work out I do all kinds of
activities and they stay in my ear it's
kind of shocking very surprising
especially because of the struggle that
I had when I first got them till the air
pods and I definitely had a rocky first
start off to our relationship because
like I said they didn't stay in my ears
but now they do so problem solved they
kept falling out in the most random and
terrible places to fall out the first
one being on airplanes
I have crawled under so many seats and
especially in some of the seats when
they get really wedged in there it's
almost impossible to get out I've had to
have flight attendants help me I've had
to have flashlights I've had strangers
digging on the ground trying to help me
find my air paws so the first time that
I'd lost my entire set of air pods I was
traveling and I just got back from
Hawaii and I looked in my person I
realized my ear pods aren't here I just
got to the airport and I thought this is
a problem because they're already sold
out so even if I were to try to buy some
now even from the Apple store I wasn't
gonna get them for another several
months that's how backorder they were
originally so I freaked out as any Apple
fan would who became obsessed with their
air pods
I ordered a pair on eBay and they
basically shipped the next day and I had
them within three days I made a video I
was freaking out said of course I was
being overdramatic just as iJustine
would and then I'd say maybe a month
later I found them that meant that I now
have two pairs of air pods which is
actually quite helpful because I would
always keep one of these inside of my
laptop case so no matter what I'd always
have a set with me when I was away the
other one stays in my purse that leads
me to maybe another month or two later I
thought that I had lost them again I
tweeted about it I was upset of course
overdramatic yet again it was okay
because I had the backup once it's
always well having - it's definitely not
necessary but of course I'm not come
because it has been nice and you're
probably saying well Justine you still
have to that's right because the missing
air pod actually was found inside of my
purse inside of like this secret little
pocket that I didn't even know existed
so back into air buds I tried a bunch of
different air pot accessory I tried the
little string that wraps around your
head and I was like this is stupid to
look good they both fell out I mean the
good news is oh gosh they fall out
they're both together if I tie this like
a room that's not gonna work my head's
not and if it was a little bit bigger I
also had one air pod stopped working
which was very upsetting because I was
on a trip with my family actually
ironically going back to Hawaii
you guys haven't noticed why is one of
my favorite places in the entire world I
just love it every time I go there I'm
just instantly happy and overjoyed and
inspired I need to move there but while
we're on the plane over there I was so
sad because one of my air pod stopped
working just completely entirely stopped
the good news we were traveling to Oahu
and there are two Apple stores on that
island so as soon as we landed I made a
Genius Bar appointment went in their
place one of my ear pods and always well
try you think there's any other crazy
air pod stories there has been times
where I'll be eating something and I'll
have my her phone just sitting here I'll
take them out I'll be like eating some
snacks or something and I can't even
tell you this has happened more than
once then I'd like to admit that I've
almost eaten an air pod because I keep
thinking it's like some sort of like a
sweet treat like a little snack like I
don't know what type of candy this would
be like popcorn I've also thought that
this was like dental floss before I'd
also thought it was a pack of gum or
like some tic tacs but now air paws
something that I'm really looking
forward to which I feel like Apple
hasn't really been talking about is the
power mat or the air power I call it
something wrong every single time so the
next version of air pods it'll have
wireless charging so with the power mat
you'll be able to charge your ear pods
your watch and your phone all at the
same time which I'm just I'm honestly
very excited for I just hope that they
announce something soon because I'm
really really looking forward to it yeah
I just to be able to place these all
down and have everything charged would
be a dream come true
hopefully we'll hear more about that
soon but in the meantime I'm still
loving my air pods like I actually
haven't found another pair of headphones
that I like more don't know if I could
even live with
I'm sure I could but do I want to know
the only time that I use real headphones
is when I'm gaming if I'm editing I do
need to use headphones because sometimes
the Bluetooth is lagging and it doesn't
have my edits on point with the music so
then I do have to use them even when I
am editing I end up just editing to the
waveforms anyway so it doesn't really
make that much of a difference I've been
loving these things and looking forward
to the next version whenever that
happens to be let me know in the
comments below what you guys think do
you love the air pods do not like them
have you lost them how many have you
lost surprisingly I have bought these
two and I have not officially
permanently lost any of them they've all
made their way back to me I'll see you
guys in my next video if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you give it
a thumbs up also be sure to subscribe
and even if you are subscribed be sure
to hit the bell because that's the only
way unfortunately that you guys will be
notified that I've posted a new video
welcome to the new YouTube I'll see you
guys in my next video
[Music]